spider-man's homecoming to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has been a huge
success for both Marvel Studios and Sony
but as amazing as Spidey's new solo
movie is there were still numerous
scenes and ideas that were deleted and
rejected from the final film yippie Kay
movie lovers it's Jan here and in this
video I'll be explaining some
fascinating scenes and concepts that
never made the final cut of homecoming
involving a whole range of characters
such as Nick Fury vulture Aunt May Tony
Stark and Captain America and they'll be
exploring the use of Peter Parker's
spider sense in the movie I'm also
running a Spider Man homecoming giveaway
at the moment for a couple of Funko pops
plus a pack of homecoming merchandise
for a chance to win make sure you
subscribe hit the bell for notifications
and leave me a comment with your
thoughts about the deleted scenes or any
future Marvel movies and quick warning
there are spoilers ahead to spider-man
homecoming so take care if you haven't
seen the movie yet in many ways it seems
totally logical that homecoming would
continue to develop Tony Stark's mentor
style relationship with spider-man from
Civil War but originally director John
watts had somebody quite different in
mind to fill that role yes as part of a
visual presentation before he landed the
job of director what created images of
former shield director Nick Fury as
Peter Parker's mentor when you think
about it it's hardly surprising that
initially what source of featuring Nick
Fury in the movie especially given the
influence on the film of Brian Michael
Bendis and marks Faculty's ultimate
spider-man comics in which Nick Fury
plays a prominent part and is even
viewed as a sort of father figure by
Peter it would have been intriguing to
see just which aspects of that comic
book interaction between Furion Spidey
that what would have brought across to
homecoming and it also would have been
nice to see samuel l.jackson back as
fury given that we've not seen him since
2006 teens age of Ultron of course Tony
Stark's presence in the new Spidey verse
provides the MCU with an easy
explanation for how such a young guy has
such an incredibly tricked-out suit of
Kevin Feige himself has said but
ultimately the reason for Iron Man's
inclusion and homecoming over Nick Fury
seems to be the Tony Stark's presence in
Peter Parker's world was one of the keys
to the deal that Marvel brokered with
Sony to bring spider-man into the MCU
fold afterall Iron Man equals big books
at the box office by the way Tom
Hollands next solo movie is spy
we'll also feature another Marvel
character birth according to The
Hollywood Reporter it's unlikely to be
Iron Man next time maybe that means
they'll be room for Nick Fury to step
into the role of guiding Spidey through
his early years as a superhero at
director Jon Watts originally envisaged
or perhaps Captain America's role could
be expanded beyond those PSA cameos and
actually that would be something Tom
Holland would be totally down with as in
a recent interview with IMDB when asked
to choose another avenge as a mental
slidy holland immediately picked Captain
America even though he thinks cap would
be stricter than Tony Stark and in the
meantime it looks like instead of
mentoring Peter Parker Nick Fury could
be appearing in Captain Marvel's first
solo movie the extent or nature of
Fury's role and the Captain Marvel film
hasn't been confirmed yet but it
wouldn't surprise me if he took on the
part of a mentor for Carol Danvers in a
similar way that Tony started with Peter
Parker and spider-man homecoming I've
got to say I did enjoy Tony Stark's role
in the film and for me it didn't feel
overwhelming which given the marketing
for the movie I had thought it might do
still marketing for the film definitely
did play up Iron Man's role in the movie
with several Iron Man and Tony Stark
shots in the trailer which didn't make
it into the final feature for example
this shot of Spider Man and Iron Man
flying was wanted specifically by the
movies marketing team for use in the
trailer there was footage of the two
together from the Staten Island Ferry
scene but John walked felt the
background with two planes so instead
they decided to put them together with a
shot of Queens in the background and
there's another scene with Tony Stark
and Peter Parker which was cut down
quite a bit from what we saw in the
trailers it takes place when tony has
his chat with Peter when they arrive
back in Queens after the events of Civil
War Peters excited that he's going to be
a big part of the Avengers now but
Tony's downplaying it with a mix of his
trademark dry humour and one-liners I
suspect what happened here is that they
shot more lines and gags than were
needed and maybe Robert Downey jr. and
Tom Holland even improvised some so to
become an Avengers other like trials or
this does not mean you're an Avenger
okay so we're wondering oh I can keep
the suit of course doesn't fit me all
right good good luck out there
Captain America Civil War introduced the
MCU to a very different aren't may than
we've seen before on the big screen
Marissa today's May is a much younger
woman who Tony Stark can't resist
flirting with but two months later
during the main timeline of spider-man
homecoming when she and Peter at a Thai
restaurant may comes right out and says
she's not a fan of Tony Stark a Marisa
Tomei reveals in an interview with Good
Morning America that was a deleted scene
of her and Tony which I think sounds
like it would clarify why she doesn't
like him to make sure she filmed a scene
where she was at a protest against dark
industries and at one point she and Tony
eyeballed each other to Mei didn't
elaborate any further so we don't know
for sure what the protest was about but
I wonder if it was anything to do with
the fallout from civil war prizes Civil
War Captain America was a war hero and
it was probably still sympathy towards
him in some sectors of the public Tony
Stark on the other hand is a billionaire
former CEO so there's no shortage of
things he could have done to draw anger
from the public it's possible some
people blamed him for splitting up the
Avengers then there are people like
Michael Keaton's tooms who are angry at
the rich and powerful who he sees as
rigging the system in their favor at the
expense of ordinary hard-working guys
like himself so I'm curious whether this
deleted scene was going to expand even
further on this team which was already
in the movie and remember in the film
Michelle said she wants to do some
protesting in Washington before the
academic decathlon well we never got to
see that either so maybe that's the
scene too may is referring to I think
it's a shame we didn't get to see Mays
protest scene as it would have helped
fill in a little bit of missing story
for a character and why she doesn't seem
to like Tony Stark I did enjoy tomatoe a
trailer park May but I think there could
have been a little more for her to do in
homecoming in fact too may have said
that she and John Watts worked on a lot
of details about May's character which
didn't make it into the film under the
trace of another deleted scene with her
in the trailers you can see in this very
short shot that Mei is walking into what
could be a classroom or an office with
what appears to be a worried look on her
face and if you look carefully behind me
there's an actress we didn't see in the
rest of the movie I think this could be
Jonah Chou who in August 2016 was
reported by variety as having been cast
in homecoming chow who's known for work
on the show's halt and catch fire and
being Mary Jane wasn't credited in the
final film and her age
confirms that her scene was cut from the
movie and according to an interview with
polygons Marissa Tomei pushed for shower
to be cast as this character who she
says is part of a revelation that
happens in the film at a very dramatic
point all of this indicates a
potentially very interesting scene cut
from the movie that hopefully we'll see
on the blu-ray release we've already
seen a couple of other main love
interests on the big screen for Spider
Man with Mary Jane in the Sam Raimi
trilogy and Gwen Stacy and the Andrew
Garfield movies so homecoming instead
introduced a new crush for Peter Parker
Liz Allen although this film does build
up the romantic connection it seems like
the filmmakers thwarted any real romance
first we had that callback to
spider-man's upside down kiss with MJ in
the first tobey maguire movie when in
this film Spidey is hanging upside down
opposite Liz after saving her from the
plummeting elevator Spidey suit Lady
Karen even says to him this is your
chance Peter
kiss her but the moment is taken away
when the webbing holding Peter breaks an
actress Laura harrier who plays Liz
Allen said in an interview with
comic-book comm that she filmed a lot of
different kissing scenes but none of
them are in the movie now and in fact we
did glimpse the kiss between them at the
homecoming dance and the trailers but
this was cut from the final movie and
given that Liz is going to move away I'm
guessing the filmmakers are closing down
any future romance between the two in
the sequel so it'll be interesting to
see if they take the route of hooking
peter up with MJ i don't know about you
but I loved Captain America's PSAs which
homecoming director John Watts got the
idea for from a long-running u.s.
program to get kids fit called the
president's challenge of course we got
to see cap speak to America's views on
subjects from keeping fits to getting
detention and we even saw the start of
or so your body is going through changes
PSA and there was also that cheeky
little fourth wall breaking one in the
post-credits about patience but
according to John watts he filmed a load
more PSAs with Chris Evans of caps that
didn't make it into the final movie
including one about brushing your teeth
and there should be even more to come
when the blu-rays released speaking of
captive shield was a shout out in the
scene where happy hogan is arranging the
roof of Avengers tech to their new
facility the items happy mentions in the
final film a cap shield
Tony's Hulkbuster armor and Thor's magic
belt
but originally director John what
co-wrote a whole page of monologues for
that scene listing out a big range of
items that happy with sorting out the
transport for now what is a fellow
Easter Egg fan so loved loading epic
movie with as many as possible but I
think in this case he made the right
decision to keep the moving gay scene
tight mentioning just three items even
if that meant we lost a bunch more
delicious Marvel Easter eggs and going
back to the trailer there was yet
another scene that didn't make it into
the movie the shot of vulture swooping
down through a hotel atrium with a scene
that John Watts perked together
specifically for a teaser at Comic Con
it was never meant to be in the movie
and was only created because what didn't
have enough material for the sizzle reel
that Marvel needed for the annual San
Diego event the scene was filmed at the
Marriott hotel in Atlanta and although
none of that shot made it into the final
film a similar take of vulture swooping
down towards the camera was used for the
villainous characters entrance in the
movie for this time with a completely
different backdrop his cruise workshop
in the comics and on-screen the
intuitive spider sense that Peter Parker
acquired after being bitten by a
radioactive spider has been an essential
part of his story and I feel like we do
see his spider sense on display at some
points during his fight scene in Captain
America Civil War there was other points
in that film he doesn't seem to have it
despite the fact that Peter specifically
tells Tony Stark that the goggles on his
homemade suit helped him focus since the
sensors have been dialed up to 11 but in
home coming apart for a few moments like
where Peter Webb grenades a body without
looking at him the filmmakers made a
specific creative decision to dial back
Peters spider sense for his first MCU
solo movie their reason being that it's
been seen so much already in Spidey's
previous films however this doesn't mean
that Peters spider sense is being
abandoned altogether in the MCU indeed
Kevin Feige has explained that their
intention is to make his spider sense
more internal to Peter and less dramatic
than it's appeared in previous cinematic
portrayals all of which makes me think
that the fact that Spidey sometimes
appears to have his spider sense and
other times doesn't maybe to do with the
fact that what we're seeing in these
movies now as a fresh take on spy these
early days of the superhero and they
want to show that he's still getting to
grips with his powers and doesn't have
full control of them I do hope that we
see Peter spiders
and progress in upcoming movies as it's
one of Spidey's greatest strengths and
it's just one of the things I love about
his character by introducing spider-man
in civil war and not going back in time
with a prequel solo movie it meant that
we didn't get Peters origin story though
frankly I don't know about you but I
really didn't need to see him get bitten
by a spider for the third time so I'm
kind of glad they skipped showing that
and gave it just a passing mention
instead and I also like the filmmakers
new spin on Peter Parker's work at the
Daily Bugle which they updated by
showing Peter's attachment to videoing
everything on his smartphone but no full
origin story also meant there was no
Uncle Ben to teach Peter that with great
power comes great responsibility it's a
shame we didn't get that classic line
which I love but there was just the
slightest allusion to a recent tragedy
when Peter says to Ned that he can't
tell art Mei about his secret web
calling activities but really overall I
thought it was better that Uncle Ben
wasn't dragged out yet again as we've
seen two recent iterations of him on the
big screen and at this point a third
Uncle Ben would have probably just felt
repetitive I would like to see Uncle
Ben's backstory teased a little further
in subtle ways in the next film however
there are fan theories out there
suggesting that Uncle Ben is actually
still alive in the MCU and in a surprise
twist could appear in a future movie now
what do you think about spider-man
homecomings deleted scenes and how do
you think homecoming in Tom Hollands
spider-man compared with the Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield spider-man
movies I'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment about the
movie for a chance to win either a
spider-man Funko pop awesome cool
official merchandise make sure you turn
on your notifications to get all my new
videos where I'll be announcing the
winners of the giveaway if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate you hitting
that thumbs up button and let me know
what movie deleted scenes you'd like me
to do in a future video in the meantime
you can check out my full movie deleted
scenes playlist here or why not watch my
epic homecoming Easter eggs video
congratulations to the second winner of
my Wonder Woman giveaway if you're the
person on the screen right now just send
me a message that I can send you the
prize thanks for watching and see you
next time you became movie lovers